so you guys are here today at the first
light of always tell me a little bit
about what you've been presenting and
what inspired you Bo's to get involved
in the industry as well well today we've
been presenting the first light in the
classroom award and it's gone to two
very talented young boys who have
created what I can see an amazing
animation called pick your brain doesn't
it oh no no it's not pick your brains
that was a clip from the movie where
it's a really clever beautiful piece of
animation that they made really succinct
sharp piece of filmmaking and it was
wonderful to see that kids you know who
are still at school you know making
really clever inventive movies future
when you were that age what kind of
thing inspired you to get involved in
the film and TV industry 16 you know I
was just sort of I mean I think that's
how how old that I was so just just
finding my feet really in the world I
don't think I was even looking at work
necessarily oh these these guys are so
far ahead of what where I was at and I
just would come into it about the age of
18 and I was doing it a college and I'm
sort of really interview so it's great
to see and I think there's even a lot of
younger kids here is also so great to
see him starting for such a young young
age inspire young kids as well as much
as it clearly does just wonderful tell
me a little bit about what you're both
doing at the moment I'm just finishing
up a play just down the way did the
Judas Kiss with Rupert Everett about
Oscar Wilde and Bodhi Douglas then a
little holiday and then then a film
about you Jason well yeah I just just
just got a little pot and a film called
welcome to the punch which is in cinemas
this weekend and yeah really pleased to
be involved in that because I was
obviously in the director's first movie
shifty which is great and then you just
shot a movie called the villain factory
which is the first spoof comedy of those
who love good films so yeah
yeah he's brilliant Joseph really
brilliant yeah speak to you guys thanks
for coming on today
you